so the key here is to recognize that you
want to eliminate one of the variables
you either want to eliminate the X's the
Y's disease now in this particular
example it looks like it's going to be
easier to start off by eliminating the
Y's so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to add the second and the third equation
together okay because I can see this is
a positive one why this is a negative
one why when we add those together the
Y's are going to cancel each other out
right so negative one X plus three X
gives us 2x y minus y is 0 2 Z plus 1 Z
is 3 Z and negative 4 plus 5 is 1 now
you can see we use the second and third
equation we want to involve that first
equation as well but again we have to
combine it either with the second or
with the third so sometimes students
forget to use all three equations so
we've used the second and third we want
to combine the first with the third or
the first with a second I'm going to
combine the first with the third because
I can see Y and negative Y if I add
those together that's going to cancel
out the Y's so let's go ahead and do
that 2x plus 3x gives us 5x and y plus
negative Y is zero and one Z plus 1 Z is
positive 2z and three plus five is eight
so now we went from three variables
three equations down to two variables
two equations right so now we have to
decide we want to eliminate the XS or
the Z's well either one is fine I'm just
gonna see if I can eliminate the Z's
because these coefficients are a little
bit smaller so what's the smallest
number that 2 goes into as well as 3
well the lowest common multiple there is
6 so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
try to get one of these to be a positive
60 the other one to be a negative 60 so
what I'm gonna do is going to multiply
this top equation by negative 3 the
bottom equation times positive 2 and all
you do is you just distribute to each of
the terms and the equation left and
right size to keep it balanced so if we
do that we get negative 15 X minus 6 Z
equals negative 24 and if we distribute
to 2 we get let's see this is positive 4
X plus 6 Z is equal to 2 now if we add
you can see the Z's are going to cancel
each other out
negative 15 Z X plus 4 X is negative 11x
and native 24 plus 2 is negative 22 if
we divide both sides of the equation by
negative 11 you can see we get x equals
2 so we went from three variables three
equations down to two variables two
equations down to one variable one
equation now we're going to work our way
back right so we're going to take x
equals two and we can put it into any of
these equations here that have two
variables I'll just go ahead and put it
into that top one so five times two plus
2z equals 8 so this gives us 10 plus 2z
equals 8 subtract 10 from both sides and
you can see you get 2z equals negative 2
divided by 2 z equals negative 1 so we
have x and z now we want to go back to
one of the original equations involving
three variables you can put it to any
one of them I'll just put it to this top
one here we've got 2 times X which is 2
plus y we don't know Plus Z which is
negative 1 equals 3 so let's see 2 times
2 is 4 plus y plus negative 1 equals 3 4
plus negative 1 is 3 and if we subtract
3 from both sides you can see Y comes
out to 0 so now what we want to do is
write our equation as a triple I'm sorry
our solution is a triple we've got X
comma Y comma Z you want to go in
alphabetical order so that's 2 0
negative 1 and that's gonna be your
final answer now if you want to check
your work go ahead and put 2 in for X 0
in for Y and negative 1 for Z in each of
these equations and you should get 3
negative 4 and 5 so it makes all the
equations true so let me erase the
whiteboard we'll do another example you
can practice on your own if you want and
we'll do that one next
okay example number two see if you can
do this one on your own what we're going
to do is we're going to solve this
system and notice that there's something
interesting about this one we're missing
a Y in this first equation so to make it
easy on us let's go ahead and focus on
eliminating the Y's this way we'll just
be left with two variables two equations
involving X and Z so you can be
strategic you know sometimes when you
are given these systems you could go
ahead and eliminate the X's or the Z's
but here the Y's are going
the easiest so I'm gonna go ahead and
add the second and third equation
together 2x + 1 x gives us 3x the Y's
cancel 1 Z plus negative 3 Z is negative
2 Z and negative 2 plus 3 is 1 I'm going
to bring the top equation over here X +
2 Z is equal to 3 now you can see we're
down to just two variables and two
equations so we can either eliminate the
axes of the Z's you can see the Z's are
gonna be a little bit easier because
once positive ones negative they're the
same coefficient all we have to do is
add straight down and you can see we're
getting 1 x + 3 x is 4 x equals 4 divide
both sides by 4 x equals 1 now all we
have to do is work our way backwards
let's go ahead and put 1 either into one
of these two equations I'll just put
into the top one so 1 plus 2z equals 3
subtract one from both sides you can see
that 2z equals 2 divide both sides by 2
and z equals 1 now we have x and z we
just have to solve for y let's go back
to one of these original equations
involving Y maybe I'll put it into the
last one here it doesn't matter which
one I'll do the third one so X is 1 Y we
don't know Z is 1 and all we have to do
is solve for y so we have 1 plus y minus
3 equals 3 1 plus negative 3 is negative
2 if we add negative 2 to both sides we
get y equals 5 and you can see our
solution is 1 comma 5 comma 1 so X Y Z
now if you want to check your work just
go ahead and put them back into the
original equations that should make them
all true and you can verify that that's
the correct solution so one last example
let me erase the whiteboard you can
practice the next one on your own if you
like and we'll go through it together
last example number three see if you can
do this one on your own the first thing
I would do here is kind of analyze what
two variable do we want to eliminate
right so do we want eliminate the X's
the Y's are the Z's well it looks like
you know anyone's going to be about the
same I think what we'll do is we'll
eliminate the the axis first so I'm
going to combine the first equation and
the third equation because you can see
if we add these together X plus negative
x those are just going to can't
another out right so X plus negative 1x
that just gives us zero negative y plus
negative three y is a negative 4y
negative Z plus 4z is 3z and 5 plus
negative 1 is 4 ok now we use the first
and the third we have to use the second
equation we either need to combine it
with the first or we need to combine it
with the third I'm going to combine it
with the third but really I want this to
be a negative 2x when I add it to
positive 2x those X's cancel so I'm
going to multiply this entire equation
times 2 so if I distribute the 2 to each
of the terms here you can see this is
going to give us negative 2x minus 6y
plus 8 Z equals negative 2 and I'm just
going to take the middle equation and
write it above it so 2x plus y plus Z
equals 7 now if we add straight down you
can see the X's are gonna cancel and we
get negative 5y plus 9 Z equals 5 so now
we're down to two variables two
equations just involving y&z do we want
to eliminate the Y's or do we want to
eliminate the Z's
it looks like the Z's are going to be
easier all we have to do is multiply
this equation by negative 3 that will
give us a negative 9z when we add it to
this one the Z's will cancel out so
let's go ahead and multiply this by
negative 3 and I'll put the answer over
here so we have negative 3 times
negative 4 y is 12 y negative 3 times
positive 3 is Z is a negative 9z and
negative 3 times 4 is negative 12 so now
if we add we can see the Z's cancel we
get 7y when we add straight down equals
negative 7 divide both sides by 7 and
you can see that y equals negative 1 all
we have to do now is work our way back
so we have y equals negative 1 we can
put it into any one of the equations
that have two variables I'll just put it
into this one right here so negative 4
times negative 1 plus 3 times Z equals 4
this gives us positive 4 plus 3 is
equals 4 we subtract 4 from both sides
you can see that 3 Z is equal to 0 if we
divide both sides by 3 Z equals 0
so we have Lions II we just need to
solve for X you can put it into any one
of the three equations that have three
variables I'm just going to put it into
this top one we've got X minus y which
is negative one minus Z which is zero
equals five negative times a negative is
a positive so that's positive one minus
0 is just 0 so we I'm not even going to
write that equals 5 and if we subtract 1
from both sides you can see that we're
getting x equals 4 and so now we want to
write our answer as a triple and we've
got 4 comma negative 1 comma 0
XYZ alphabetical and again if you want
to check your work you can put it back
in make sure it makes all equation is
true if you want to find out how to
handle when you have no solution or a
general solution check out that video
that I did right there and I'll go into
how to solve for a general solution or
when there's no solution I'll see you in
the next video